hallo mein name ist programm wir spielen
heute de berry organized rief das heißt
wir sind ein organisierter de talca wir
sind ein organisierter die wir würden ja
wir fahren einfach mal an tablets space
gedrückt und jetzt sind wir mal ganz
kurz
angeblich ist es doch kein horror spiel
da unten steht muss mit bas de
holzschiff touran dann und was muss ich
jetzt hier genau machen ok mit der
rechten maustaste kann ich nicht an und
ausmachen
sogar die schatten funktionieren da das
bin ich von diesem internet games
eigentlich nie gewohnt mit linksklick
kann ich sachen
sind das augen dahin ich spiele das
gerade mitten in der nacht hätte gedacht
dass so ein scheiß spaß spiele sieht
aber tatsächlich recht mysteriös aus ich
mach mal left to run und jetzt mal ein
bisschen show ach so ich musste einfach
mal rennen damit losgeht ich kann eh
drücken dann wird die ok das ist genau
das gleiche was ich mit recht machen
kann das hier ist meine checklist
portrait of lady tablet gitarre silva
candlestick die wie die player mobile
von dick ist meine taschenlampe gerade
alle gegangen digitalkamera und mit gold
war
ich will nicht dass das horrorspiel ist
das tablet habe ich dann brauche ich
noch portrait of lady guitar silva kenne
ich will dich so den dvd player haben
wir jetzt auch ich habe angst dass einer
kommt
da nicht die familie kommt er zu hause
da kommt jetzt aber nicht die familie
galt
das ist jetzt aber nein ich bin ich hier
ich bin ich hier ich bin ich hier ich
bin nicht wie komme ich denn
ach und man hat immer neue sachen sonst
könnte ich ja diesen einwand schnell
einsammeln aber ich mache jetzt mal
einfach irgendwie schnell dran ich denke
mir hier erst mal kurz den money slap
dann einig tschuldigung fernseher
microwave dafür muss ich ja glaub ich in
die küche oder dann gehe ich mal kurz
hier da genauso die microwave dann
brauche ich eine bracelet was ist ja
okay was genauso man bracelet google
sagt ein bracelet ist ein armband ach ja
stimmen dich dummkopf
aber wo finde ich hier ein armband hier
einfach mal ein rasenmäher mit und macht
reichtum kommt das tablet das so gewollt
denn hier ein tablet pc schon kommen die
kommen gleich hier an wiedermann ist das
packe ich kenne jetzt mal einfach hier
nach oben um zu schauen was hier oben
kann es auch noch überall rein oder wie
es ist tatsächlich ganz geil gemacht ich
kann nämlich mit allen irgendwie
interagieren ich kann überall so ein
bisschen geld mitnehmen ich kann alle
schubladen irgendwie ausmachen
hier ist noch ein das ist doch das
bracelet auch nur da oben drin ist
wahrscheinlich richtig viel aber werten
den code glaube ich unten gelassen oder
wo habe ich denn den court noch mal
gesehen wo ich hab' ich habe irgendeine
schublade aufgemacht oder an dieser
cacau das war oben nach oben 2357 dann
gebe ich hier einfach mal ein
2357 sollte
toll
nein nach hause kommen an frist verlangt
nein dieses spiel macht so fucking viel
spaß deswegen spiel wird gerade direkt
nochmal
eine vase finde ich eine vase ich kann
ja eigentlich auch tatsächlich mal rein
theoretisch hier überall licht anmachen
und habe ich sehr viel einfacher ist
dann vielleicht tatsächlich nicht so
sinnvoll wenn der typ nach hause kommt
egal ich habe tatsächlich noch nichts
gefunden was ich hier irgendwie
mitnehmen sollen
ich bin so ein schlechter die ich mal
wieder den typischen weg erst mal hier
in office rein um dann hier mehr drin
es ist nicht wirklich schon mit danach
gerade oder hier wieder schön alles
rausnehmen so ein bisschen gelb blau und
jetzt auch okay die gold bei haben wir
schon so die vase hier vorne haben wir
auch als ob der jetzt schon nach hause
kommen
ich verstecke mich jetzt im badezimmer
der kann mich eigentlich
ich habe über licht angelassen
bitte bitte bitte bitte nicht ich glaube
man hat sich noch niemand versteckt ich
glaube es funktioniert
ich glaube er kann uns gar nicht hier
drin finden
mein herz soll ich noch mal irgendwann
zweiten teil davon hochladen
ich glaube dabei stelle ich dann
komplett einer war das laut wenn euch
das video gefallen hat würde ich mich
über eine positive bewertung freund mein
herz tötet mich gerade ich habe am
anfang kurzzeitig gedacht ist ein doch
ein horrorspiel dann habe ich gesorgt
denn als mit mir aufgefallen und er
seine kindliche grafikers kein horror
spiel und dann habe ich mich am ende
noch mit übels erschrocken
mein herz macht sowas einfach nicht mehr
tut mir leid